bonjour à tous salut Laurent
yes salut à tous alors on a ce petit
match là de proces League est-ce que tu
peux nous rappeler un petit peu Laurent
la fiche du deuxième match d'aujourd'hui
s'il te plaît
avec Nakamura quand même
non mais c'est comme tout à l'heure
[Musique]
vu que tu es en
ça devrait marcher là
c'est vraiment c'est un truc du micro
qui était qui était bien disant je
reprends mes vieux trucs bon en tout cas
salut Stéphane salut à tous on prend 2-0
pour un petit match écoute pour un grand
match avec
Ikaru Nakamura le meilleur journal
j'étais en train de dire ça ça me fait
mal au cœur je sais pas avec Magnus ça
se tient à pas grand chose en tout cas
mais il a gagné le dernier match de
speechers
c'est très très chaud donc on va
regarder ça évidemment on va saluer nos
amis de Blist Stream qui nous ont tenu
en haleine à vite partout alors j'ai
suivi il y avait 7,5 pour les autres je
donnais pas cher de leur peau
honnêtement et eux non plus d'ailleurs
ils étaient en petite non Isabelle
d'être un peu ouais il commence à dire
ouais de toute façon on savait que
c'était fort en face et au final la
remonte à là quoi j'ai entendu de toute
façon l'important c'est de participer
alors ça c'est quand même c'est le truc
c'est le truc très très mauvais signe si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc on
entendrez pas ici en tout cas de de ma
bouche moi ce truc qui c'est pas c'est
pas dans mon vocabulaire mais en tout
cas bravo à eux ils ont fait 8 partout
ils sont à l'arrachés ce taille break et
grichu notamment a fait
une très grosse partie là on l'a à
l'image hors si ça ça si ça ça marche
vous inquiétez pas on va voir les
caméras et tout ça on se met en place et
on a vu une Master Class de greachu
camblis Maxime Vacher la grave a fait
d'une contre Nara nayan mile Boyer
abattu mitraba et c'était le clutch
c'était 2,5 a perdu finalement son
Bleach je sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
suivi ça mais voilà de toute façon ça
jouait plus donc bravo à la team vite
alors évidemment c'est pas gagné hein ça
ça reste la première ronde mais contre
une grosse équipe en face c'était du
très lourd
ah ouais en plus ces Indiens ils sont
hyper dangereux quoi quand tu vois juste
n'a rien
dit aux deux premiers déjà c'est c'est
mon truc c'est monstrueux alors
tu me demandais comment ça marche cette
processing en fait ils vont jouer c'est
un système suisse donc comme dans les
open ce que dans le chat qui ont fait
déjà des Open donc vous connaissez le
système suisse bien sûr on gagne après
on va jouer un joueur qui a gagné et si
on perd on joue un joueur qui a perdu et
que comme il n'y a pas de match nul ça
ça roule bien et voilà il y aura
quelques équipes éliminées après
quelques semaines alors exactement le
détail de la formule je crois que c'est
trois équipes après trois semaines après
trois semaines de compète ensuite la
semaine d'après encore deux on est quand
même comme ça pour arriver au quart de
finale et les 8 meilleurs équipes qui
vont se disputer la victoire finale ça
sera beau et pour aujourd'hui donc le
petit match
selon la police
extraordinaire qui nous attend bon donc
on a berline Beers Stéphane écoute avec
des joueurs allemands qui sont solides
qui savent ce qu'ils font je sais pas si
tu les connais déjà
c'est la jeune enfin hier c'est la
jeunesse quoi on va
une race muse on va Collard si on voit
l'autre Sven aussi c'est vrai que c'est
bon c'est les jeunes qui ont quoi 25 ans
quoi ouais à tout cassé vraiment alors
Frédéric zen j'ai pas la rêve je connais
pas rassemble
très très bien je l'ai fait au bout de
sliga pas tous les week-ends
pareil et Joséphine a une Mann qui est
une qui est là quasiment la meilleure
chose allemande elle doit numéro 2
derrière pète mais très forte aussi et
en face on a le king du journal e-caru
Nakamura évidemment le King de chasot
com bon est-ce qu'on le présente IKA ou
Stéphane moi je pense que tout le monde
le connaît ici carou hein
vraiment les deux meilleurs joueurs les
deux meilleurs joueurs du monde online
et donc icaru en plus souvent c'est un
streamer maintenant tu es voilà
j'en ai entendu parler du coup
j'ai même regardé en stream il a une
énergie incroyable je sais pas
il est il est il est assez il est assez
incroyable
bon ces commentaires sur
moi j'ai surtout regardé quand il
commentait la fin animal oui il disait
non j'ai rien dit et puis après il a
parlé par une demi-heure bon bref donc
c'est assez drôle au deuxième on a alors
les coins de Liège on est bien c'est un
joueur vietnamien numéro vietnamien
depuis de nombreuses années alors gros
client les coins de liams
[Musique]
Tours il faisait toujours très fort il
est il est sérieux il est sérieux ça va
être quelque chose
du monde de blé lui il a été champion du
monde de blé
donc c'est pas tu vois il est numéro 2
derrière Nakamura quand même c'est ça
montre un petit peu au niveau de
l'équipe quoi ils ont les deux premiers
euh bah incroyable et ensuite ils ont
Andy wood Wars que je connais pas trop
mais bon ils ont dû faire les choses
bien je sais pas s'il est anglais ou
américain on verra on découvrira je sais
pas si tu le connais
une idée non et ouais ouais donc on le
connaît pas lui mais bon 2447 au
compteur donc un très bon joueur et
Nathalie à bouxa alors je la connais ça
joue bien ça joue bien
pour suivre les deux matchs les deux
matchs alors
fou contre tigre et bouledogue contre
je crois que c'est les je crois que le
fou c'est c'est Saint-Louis Bishop
quelque chose là et je crois avec
tout à l'heure du coup bah est-ce que je
peux te le dire en direct non mais tu
vois on découvre cette première semaine
moi c'est ce que je dis rien ne se joue
la première semaine comme dans toutes
les compétitions qui s'étale comme ça
sur deux mois mais effectivement on
découvre les les forces en présence et
voilà on peut juger de chacun on a vu
aujourd'hui moi je trouve qu'entre Blitz
l'équipe indienne et Gotham on est quand
même assez servi on a des on a des gros
candidats à la victoire finale
clairement les deux premiers jours si je
vais pas comme ça il y a l'équipe
indienne peut-être qui était forte le
premier jour et évidemment les chaises
braves avec avec Magnus avec un leader
comme ça il faut toujours se méfier
parce que comme il l'a fait le premier
jour il peut coller
numéro 4 donc ça c'est toujours ça
s'arrange tous les affaires quand c'est
le premier à 8h30 on va découvrir ça
d'ailleurs cadence 10 + 2 les
compositions d'équipe ne fait pas ne
peuvent pas dépasser une moyenne et
l'eau de 2550 chaque joueur affronte
tous les jours tous les jours de
l'équipe adverse pour un total de 4 ans
d'après l'équipe à 8h30 en porte le
match en cas d'égalité des partages
déterminer l'équipe gagnante là on est
sur deux tailles break consécutifs à mon
avis il y en aura pas aujourd'hui allez
je me lance pas non plus
dépendre de la forme de d'un cas devant
parce que bon si il n'y a qu'un il joue
enfin tu as l'impression que si il joue
bien il va tout raser quoi déjà tu vois
tu as déjà vu une incapable enfant toi
[Rires]
il a perdu contre Magnus au dernier
champion de gestion dans la première
étape de ce champion
je sais pas comment il l'appelle
exactement je crois que c'est toujours
champion de chaise tours mais en tout
cas c'est sur c'est sur Chess.com aussi
c'est un voilà ils ont décidé de
évidemment de créer une synergie à
partir des tournois qui existaient avant
et de créer un truc assez extraordinaire
en trois divisions avec tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde donc c'est à
suivre il y aura 5 ou 6 tournois dans
l'année on va regarder les tie-break je
le dis depuis le début remake de la room
4 couleurs inversé ça se joue pas sur un
seul beats joue sur 4 Blitz en cas de
nouveau match nul on l'a vu on passe à
un plus de alors ça on l'a pas encore
fait on avait ça encore les couleurs
les joueurs continuent d'inverser les
couleurs jusqu'à une certaine heure on
ne sait pas enfin jusqu'à ce qu'une
équipe l'emporte en tout cas s'il y a
que des matchs nulles et bien sur un
point de vue théorique ça peut durer
pendant deux ans
allô
je suis en stress parce que tu me parles
plus pendant 10 secondes j'ai peur il y
a un truc qui est cassé donc parle-moi
tout le temps s'il te plaît alors
là je vois il y a marqué c'est quoi
c'est ils ont fait un peu n'importe quoi
je crois les appareils tu as vu non je
vois rien là pour l'instant
alors je crois que c'est la même équipe
non je dis n'importe quoi mais
normalement c'est
alors là il y a marqué Colars contre
philippin auto à 1864 je pense pas que
ce soit Nakamura non non
des trucs un peu bizarres
alors on a donc tu nous confirmes que ce
vein Rasmus a les Noirs d'accord ça
c'est une belle info
il a les Noirs
je pourrais te donner après si tu veux
j'ai super comme ça je pourrais
m'organiser à la poste parce que là vous
voyez j'ai fait c'est beaucoup mieux
c'est beaucoup mieux que les autres
jours là
je peux mais par contre l'autre stream
ne marche pas donc ça je peux rien faire
si les joueurs sont pas là en tout cas
ça c'est parti écoute ils ont fait vite
à commencer
je les vois pas du tout
et c'est bizarre parce que là je voyais
marqué il y a philippin auto qui
s'appelle le joueur avec les Blancs ah
alors ça doit être je les vois donc il
faudrait voir il faudrait voir comment
il s'appelle avec les Blancs c'est pour
ça
ah voilà
mais on essaye d'avoir ma télé on l'a à
l'écran bon là l'écran la télé
la comment ça se fait
ajuster mais c'est un peu
elle était bien dans le dans le truc
mais bon voilà la partie qu'on a devant
les yeux c'est bien beau que ça contre
contre je vérifie juste
ouais c'est bien ça c'est fort faible
première partie c'est un contre quatre
et du coup je joue aujourd'hui que les
parties sont décalés en fait ça veut
dire que la partie commence une après
les autres ouais c'est ça et pas en même
temps
c'est ça c'est pas mal pour nous ça
c'est pas mal pour moi en tout cas moi
je suis absolument d'accord alors
ouais je te laisse faire le petit le
petit commentaire là parce que je suis
donc ça c'est la partie ça c'est bien
pour que ça c'est bien ça contre zen
donc c'est une sorte d'italienne qui
qui a marché un peu bizarrement là j'ai
l'impression
que le centre la paire de fou pour les
Noirs c'est pour ça donc qu'est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer ici peut-être un petit
défi avec fougères qui va être pas mal
avec les Blancs
pour essayer de taper son cavalier F3
qui lui aime défendre le pion des 4 tout
à fait bah de toute façon il faut sortir
les dernières pièces on fait
ok
le 7
ok donc là c'est position un petit peu
un petit peu tu vois
ouais on voit là par nous pour le noir
par défaut contrôle le centre des blancs
donc
je sais pas trop comment avaler cette
position Laurent
alors c'est toujours pareil
[Musique]
c'est compliqué parce que les les deux
côtés ont des en des atouts clairement
donc le centre hein comme tu l'as dit et
la paire de fou quand même pour les
noirs
donc je sais pas moi je suis tenté de
dire égal quand c'est comme ça mais
effectivement c'est la seule fois la
facilité là mais effectivement
normalement c'est vraiment pas sensé
être dangereux pour les pour les Noirs
ce genre de système mais pour que ça qui
est
on fait pas de people ici normal en fait
je crois pas je sais pas tu vas
m'apprendre vu que tu es là très très
régulièrement depuis de quelques années
de nombreuses années je sais pas depuis
combien de temps d'ailleurs mais
pas tant que ça d'accord mais en tout
cas on fait pas de people mais en tout
cas elle est elle est mariée au grand
maître international Raouf mamedov qui
est lui-même un expert de ces petites
variantes voilà donc je pense qu'il
discutait chèque en général dans un
couple de joueurs d'échec il y a un
moment où on sort la pendule on fait des
Blitz c'est en discuter chèque c'est dur
de d'y échapper je je sais quelque chose
voilà donc
il lui manque des petites variantes et
clairement j'ai déjà vu j'ai déjà j'ai
déjà remarqué ça ou parfois moi j'ai
joué Raph au Top 16 l'année dernière et
je commençais à regarder les parties de
son épouse
pour voir un petit peu aussi est-ce
qu'on dirait pas voir IKO
on va voir comment ils se débrouille
donc il a les Noirs contre Joséphine a
une Mann je vais vous trouver ça tout de
suite
alors je crois que c'était la moi
des 6 7 5 non j'y crois pas tu sais que
j'ai fait une vidéo là-dessus ah ouais
j'ai fait une vidéo là dessus mais en
fait c'est monstrueux parce que c'est de
longue histoire en fait si tu veux c'est
c'est François Bret qu'il a qui avait
trouvé cette ligne avec Yoha
et
tu sais que François Abrets il a il a
battu saaric en blitz en 3 + 2 c'était
Corsica Masters
abandon
en fait il y a un gros gros piège et du
coup j'avais demandé à Yoha si je
pouvais faire une vidéo là-dessus vu que
c'était un peu c'était un peu elle tu
vois qu'il y avait
popularisé cette ligne qui qui aurait
pas terrible mais il y a un gros piège
monstrueux sur 17,5 et Elman n'est pas
tombé dedans elle a joué aux échecs
normalement et elle a joué trois etc
donc en fait à 115 blanche on voit qu'il
y a un gros problème quand même chez les
noirs
mais il faut savoir qu'après F5 je crois
que tu es censé être à moins de
ah oui c'est ça
des pièges mais moi je les ai deux fois
en partie lente et j'ai battu un ami il
y a quelques mois et c'est un mec qui
jouait qui est hyper solide et qui joue
son petit système tout le temps des 4 G3
etc il m'avait une fille dehors il y a
deux ans il m'avait joué l'avance la
vente d'échange et reposer nul au
quatrième coup
j'avais refusé pour essayer de jouer bon
on avait quand même fait nul et là il
m'a rejoué tu vois il marche pareil et
du coup quand j'ai quand il m'a fait il
m'a fait T4 D6 et E4 et j'ai fait F5
et là il a réfléchi 20 minutes il m'a
fait n'importe quoi et la collapse
complet en fait alors
ça ça peut arriver ouais ça peut arriver
ce genre de choses mais tu parles de
François Bret figure-toi qui m'a battu
avec ça en simultané
c'est pas lui qui a simultané encore ce
genre d'entends encore parler de cette
partie il était fier oh là là il était
content et donc voilà ça ça m'étonne ça
m'étonne pas et on aille Carouge j'ai
l'impression qu'il stream en même temps
je sais pas si tu le vois il est en
train de parler il est extraordinaire
ricao
tu as le droit de stream en fait la
question il a quand même des règles
spéciales je vais le noter ça en fait tu
peux stream mais je crois que le chat
doit être un émoticône pour éviter que
de l'aide
pour éviter qu'on te donne des coups ou
un truc comme ça
donc
entre Joséphine qui bon ben évidemment
400 points au départ alors
c'est compliqué il est déjà gagnant là
c'est ça on est d'accord il est déjà oh
là là c'est la cata là c'est la cata
déjà alors c'est c'est quoi la
réputation vas-y réfute ta propre
variante dis-nous
le piège c'est qu'elle va laisser trois
tu veux je te montre le piège enfin
c'est c'est
trois prises
et là tu peux faire cavaler prends au
fou des trois comme tu veux
et je vous fout des trois par exemple là
c'est qu'avait les C6 en fait
et sur le cas ici bah tu dis ben je
prends F6 puis
c'est faute dommage 5 à cause de ça et
le meilleur le meilleur
d'accord non non
et il faut que je fous 3 et là qui
avaient les B4 faut pas manger et là en
fait il y a une vente qui fait nulle
mais c'est un jouable je crois que la
ligne c'est que tu es petit rock c'est
rock dans le 4 et surtout des deux dames
G2 et sur foie H6 la pointe c'est fou
aussi et bon ok c'est maison ça et là tu
bouffes 3D 7 dame G7
3 C6 et la seule coup D5 et je crois que
la ligne je crois que c'est D5 fous
prend et B3 sinon tu as perdu
mais bon on va comprendre ça quoi vous
jouez
même analyser des lignes perdants c'est
ça que je
en fait en fait c'est marrant tu vois
parce que bon quand tu quand tu sais au
lit un jour tu vois c'est pas si bon
c'est pas bon mais
voilà quoi et du coup c'était c'était
François qui me l'avait montré il avait
analysé de ouf avec Yoha et puis moi je
l'avais jamais joué parce que c'est pas
des échecs et puis après mais tiens ça
marrant quoi et du coup je l'ai joué un
petit peu en stream je l'ai même joué en
équipe là j'ai battu un ami et
voilà quoi bon maintenant j'ai arrêté
parce que bon c'est pas ce que ça allait
c'est compliqué quand même
ouais et puis en plus franchement tu
tombes jamais dans la ligne avec avec
d'un match 5 les mecs à chaque fois ils
te font F5 vie ou en fait tu tombes
jamais là dessus voilà mais regarde moi
ça ce qui fait de la il est bien tombé
alors effectivement
Joséphine et dépassé là par les
événements mais tellement de tellement
de monde en jouant contre
son dépassé par les événements c'est dur
de pas être dépassé je suis sûr qu'après
H4 il va faire j'ai trois je connais par
cœur on fait pas le but
il a vraiment un aura quoi quand tu
joues conclue en plus le fait qu'il soit
hyper fort et ben tout le monde a peur
de le conclu tout le monde c'est comme
quoi
le petit lion là Wonder quoi qui a
complètement tilté il a pas changé voilà
ben je pense que c'est le statut
champion du monde qui aussi bien sûr ça
joue et puis ils sont quand même très
résistants il faut avouer que l'un comme
l'autre il n'est pas du tout il donne
pas de pions il joue quand il est 5 il
se pressent pas il va faire cavalier F4
alors je suppose que j'ai trois semble
être le coup mais
ça donne des des cases ici donc c'est
c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué pour pour Joséphine là
peut tomber
roi G1 elle a joué bon est-ce qu'on
reste avec avec Naka où on fait un petit
tour des stades
donc si tu veux je suis en bas
on va voir Frédéric qu'on avait tout à
l'heure face à l'ecouen Guyane donc il a
les blancs Frédéric
il est dans la même équipe que Joséphine
donc il va être en haut
je suis reparti pour pour un tour de
réglage j'aime bien les blancs ici les
positions un petit peu tu peux lancer G5
avec la petite paire de fou sur le roi
voilà il faut que j'ai deux il est pas
sur le roi mais tu imagines les fous B2
qui va arriver avec G5 qui pousse mais
c'est laquelle d'être assez bizarre à la
pollution la position des blancs
là il y a un pion arrière en D3 quand
même
et il faut stocker une qualité non il y
a
il y a deux pièces pour la tour OK et
puis on isolé
il y a deux pions pour le 2 pièces
intéressantes
[Musique]
j'ai pas accès au
noir de jouer pardon
1 + 1 = 3
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici non lui
c'est pas le Kang ouais je sais bien
j'ai la poisse j'avais une chance sur
deux j'ai quand même
je te jure j'ai Gamble la chanson de
c'est affreux voilà
je vais renommer mais je suis à
l'ancienne j'ai un petit j'ai un petit
j'ai stylo papier un petit papier ouais
je faisais ça aussi avec les avec les
avec
18 caméras mais là tu peux le renommer
directement tu fais clic droit renommer
j'aime bien je suis désolé j'aime bien
j'aime bien mon papier je suis désolé je
suis très je suis très heureuse sur ça
j'aime bien le papier pas que sur ça sur
toi je suis très old school pour
beaucoup de choses et notamment pour ça
où j'aime bien et moi aussi moi je
marque tous mes papiers là j'ai dit là
j'ai regarde j'ai encore mes papiers là
je te montrer à la caméra j'ai encore
mais mais mes goûts Kech là je marquais
webcam un par un
j'avais 18 caméras au tabac style avec
sur les joueurs donc à chaque fois que
je sache quelle caméra avec les Orchies
parce que sinon c'est chiant quoi mais
on va voir c'est en train c'est en train
de
ça va être plus en place pour les pour
les prochaines rangs surtout si on a les
appareils à l'avance effectivement ouais
mais en fait je les ai apparemment et
donc ça c'est très bien
d'accord alors les Noirs ils ont deux
pièces enfin ils ont tout et deux pions
pour deux pièces et une belle structure
de pion moi j'aime bien
moi aussi j'aime bien les blancs avec G5
qui peut arriver c'est une petite galère
assez pas facile à jouer pour le noir
mais la jauge a l'air de dire que les
noirs sont vieux donc ça c'est un peu
étonnant
ouais en fait il croit pas l'attaque
mais alors que nous en fait en tant
qu'humain avec les Blancs on sait quoi
faire
et c'est plus dur avec les Noirs moi il
y a plus 1 à 4 renards quand même hein
faut pas oublier ah c'est vrai mais
justement c'était c'était pas vu c'était
pas vu comment
et du coup ce pur un cadre une fois que
je le bouffe j'ai quand même deux pions
passés
abond il faut il faut être sûr qu'il se
passerait là-bas mais il réfléchit
d'ailleurs les Kong d'ailleurs est-ce
que je ferais pas un truc comme ça tu
vois pour aller te pour me venger direct
pourquoi pas crédit ici et regarde ce
qu'il a joué
bon je sais pas c'est quoi son idée sur
la mode c'est juste de faire un truc
je sais pas si ça te va je pense qu'il
veut
ton avis savoir si ça vaut le coup de
donner le foutage blanche mais je crois
que je crois que tactiquement
il s'est passé un truc excuse-moi je
crois qu'il vient de Blender non regarde
ce qu'il fait
je sais pas c'est quoi là
mais alors on est alléger décalage on
rappelle on mesure un petit triche donc
il a probablement on va voir dame G3 et
là il y a dû se passer alors comment il
a blender on va essayer de voir est-ce
que ça se passe G2
il y a des gens qui qui bougent d'abord
leur tu fais ça toi
ça m'arrive de faire un truc comme ça en
fait tu vois
[Musique]
[Rires]
les noms de la tête mais il joue encore
ouh là par contre il va rater qui avait
lieu d'échec
en PLS apparemment
on va voir alerte
je remets Naka oh il fait non la tête on
a qu'à voilà
il s'est passé quoi
ça c'est la position c'est pas la
position ça
non c'est ça la position
on va regarder ce qui s'est passé mes
priorités au direct elle est où
Joséphine on va essayer de voir tout de
suite le point le point tout à l'heure
en forme et qui fait nappe bah en fait
le match il est pas clair et on voit
Joséphine à l'écran c'est énorme ce
qu'elle est en train de faire
c'est juste énorme
regardez-moi ça
c'est arrivé elle a plus qu'une minute
mais regardez elle a deux dames de plus
c'est complètement terminé même pour les
carunakamura
est-ce que c'est la joueuse cette parce
qu'il y a pas d'échec
contre l'âge de
est-ce qu'il a fait n'importe quoi pour
arriver là-dedans on va regarder ça il
est en train de jouer il rigole et ouais
mais regardez la position qu'il avait
c'était assez extraordinaire qui est des
5000 logements un peu vite
comme quoi faut se méfier on l'avait dit
que Joséphine c'était une très très
bonne chose toi j'ai 8 ans
F3 et d'un F6 qui apparemment madame F6
pour prendre un H4 mais c'est un peu
naïf
il perd toute cette pièce là bah là on
attaque on protège il a raté fouger 5
une hallucination et cavalier 3
cavaliers à la fin joliment jouer et il
y a plus du tout d'attaque et maintenant
on menace de tout liquider par là oh là
là là là
incroyable à ce niveau là en fait même à
ce niveau là ça blender et elle a bien
elle a bien terminé le truc
qui a battu Caro Nakamura elle est
contente il y a de quoi il y a de quoi
être content
je crois que là c'est voilà donc il y a
un partout dans ce match qui commence
vraiment de manière
écoute surprenantes pour le mois quand
même pour le coup de savoir ce qui
raconte Naka ici là ça fait pas non non
il est abandonné là d'accord en les
voyants encore ok donc on voit Nathalie
à bouxa qui est l'autre joueuse
je vais la
n'était pas bien je vous le fais ah non
je me trompe donc à 0 1 0 pour pour
l'équipe de alors les c'était hyper
c'est ça
use j'ai un peu du nom exact Berlin
berts
on va aller voir
ce qui s'est passé le missclic tour à un
dame prend un ouais regardez ce qu'on
avait dit ça liquide mais regardez
maintenant c'est là c'est typiquement
tour trois pions contre deux pièces et
en plus c'est des beaux pions
abandon abandon de Sven Frédéric tandis
que on a pas eu le temps de les voir là
on a rien vu d'entre Philippines auto
qui en fait Woods Ward contre
[Musique]
Collard et
et ouais on le connaissait pas ce wood
Wars on a pas le temps de faire
connaissance du coup
et déjà parti ouais il est déjà dans il
est pas parti on va on va faire
connaissance à la prochaine mais il a
déjà pris une bulle quoi
bon ben Colars on vous l'avez dit un
Collard son truc il aime pas laisser du
contre jeu si vous voyez ce qu'on ce que
je veux dire bon voilà technique bien
propre
Deutsch qualitat ouais non superbe
superbe
vraiment
vraiment très impressionnant il faut que
je descende parce que les parties sont
toutes terminées et 3-1 donc première
portion franchement
je pense
erasmusven qui a battu bu que ça bah
écoute 3h ça relance le match on va
s'arrange le match nous on pensait qu'il
était foutu avant un petit match mais
finalement Naka qui perd
c'est quand même un choc surprise parce
qu'en fait c'est pas trop surprenant
jusque là il y a pas eu de de résultat
tu vas dramatique je veux dire les
favoris ont gagné à chaque fois il y a
une non partie c'est vrai tableau 2
quand même avec un
slip de kg quand même mais Nakamura qui
perd ça c'est par contre la l'énorme
surprise tu nous donnes les appareils de
la de la ronde 2 alors contre qui va
jouer les Caro Nakamura il aura les
blancs alors normalement je l'ai vu tout
à l'heure comment c'était un but de
seconde parce que j'ai trop de liens
il aura les blancs après a priori
carreau pour se refaire à mon avis elle
est blanc contre Frédéric
en fait du coup ronde 2 c'est A1 en fait
si tu veux tu as a A et B donc ah
j'imagine que c'est les Verts
donc B1 c'est contre A3 donc normalement
il va jouer contre contre
qui est je commence comme ça voilà
normalement je pense
donc 1 B3 ça va être ça va être astuce
c'est la Numéro 6 alors je vais
de ce pas
violent c'est violent et Nakamura qui
qui tu vois comme quoi c'est c'est pas
c'est pas gagné d'avance tu peux blender
tu peux
te perdre
c'est quand même c'est quand même
[Musique]
étonnant
qui a un des meilleurs joueurs du monde
ah non la 6 c'est c'est Joséphine ça
doit être la 7 alors
et Joséphine elle aurait pas les Noirs
par hasard ça marche
à 4 elle joue contre B2 elle est le noir
contre B2
ce serait du coup le temps
s il a quoi il est blanc
contre contre Joséphine normalement
si je dis pas de bêtises
ça serait cool
cette image ah ouais ça va nous
ouais
hyper
hyper fluide ensuite ouais c'est ça donc
du coup ça va être rassemus veine contre
Andy ou quoi
veine contre
surestime largement
ici donc OK et blanc Sven mais j'ai pas
son numéro de
blanc contre wood world
ouais mais j'ai pas leur numéro vas-y et
le dernier
Collard
on va chercher alors
et ensuite
les deux joueurs qui ont perdu la partie
qui ont accès
Frédéric il a les Noirs quand on a qu'à
d'accord ça c'est le 8 et le 7 je suis
vraiment je suis désolé je suis perplexe
il faudrait
[Musique]
faudrait plus ou moins là un producteur
ah non mais c'est lui
là oui oui parce que la qualité
donc
[Musique]
je vous le dis
et en plus
je crois que c'est autorise le stream si
tu mets tout en émoticônes pour éviter
pour éviter vraiment les bons la triche
donc le 7 c'est rassemus Swain et le 5
c'est qui le dernier de l'équipe il y a
les frères Sven et le 5 c'est Colars et
collars il aura quoi comme couleur
[Musique]
il a blanc contre boxa
d'accord
après non après tu vois des fois on
pense que le fait de stream et bien ça
te fait moins bien joué et je pense que
pour certaines personnes c'est le cas
parce que moi un témoin focus etc mais
n'a qu'à lui
je te dis moi je l'ai vu mettre 10 euros
donc franchement j'ai l'impression que
n'a qu'à en fait il a son instinct qui
est tellement monstrueux que la tête
c'est même mieux quand il réfléchit pas
il est hyper surprenant et
voilà quoi mais je pense que non moi je
trouve ça cool
il va jouer le il a les blancs
[Musique]
on va le connaître un peu parce qu'on
sait pas ah c'est le jeune là
je comprends pourquoi ils l'ont mis
parce qu'il a l'air d'avoir 12 ans il a
probablement allez on va essayer de voir
ce que ça donne par là et on va voir
évidemment
Iker unakamura qui est là avec les
Blancs et jouera face à
tu vas me le rappeler c'est le troisième
c'est sveinds Asus
Weiner et voilà je vais le trouver tout
de suite
on voit on voit souvent qui a fait
cavaler G5 dans la partie d'avant qui a
qui a fait un Mao sleep y a pas une
pièce dans un coup et Naka qui a
complètement aussi blender plat partie
donc du coup du coup le match des
des
matchs des deux joueurs qui ont qui ont
pu le faire dans la partie
je me porte important quoi surtout pour
zwen je pense qui vient de perdre une
partie difficile et qui enchaîne avec
les Noirs quand on a qu'à
salut blender
[Musique]
salut blood drink
alors c'est un tournoi qui cette tournoi
par équipe un par ville je crois après
il fallait vraiment justifier il y a des
années fallait justifier que tu habitais
bien d'un tel ou telle ville où tu avais
déjà fait un truc ça c'est que tu
habitais ou que tu avais un lien
quelconque avec la ville donc soit tu
avais été dans un club ou dans une école
ou un truc voilà quoi et à l'époque
c'était ça et du coup bon maintenant
c'est plus par affinité ils ont foutent
un peu on envoie des joueurs tu vois
comme je pense que booksa et Nakamura
ils ont pas la ville en commun en tout
cas etc voilà
donc du coup voilà c'est ton appareil
qui chaque joueur va rentrer tout le
monde et puis il y a un système de
poules
10 + 2 les compétitions d'équipe donc il
y a il y a 10 joueurs sur Alice maximum
mais il y a quatre joueurs qui sont
sélectionnés pour chaque rang de moyenne
et l'autre de 2550 maximum
sachant qu'un joueur a plus de 2700
compte comme un jouet à 2700 et une
joueuse à plus de 2350 compte comme une
joueuse à 2350 qui est évidemment ce qui
incite les les équipes à recruter les
meilleurs et les meilleurs et les
meilleurs reux joueuses et joueurs donc
voilà bon ça c'est une certaine logique
sans qu'une équipe puisse écraser toute
la compétition sinon Magnus Naka et et
où une femme se mettra ensemble il y
aurait plus trop de suspense tandis que
là c'est très chaud
et la première équipe
2007 quoi
ouais non mais oui tu vois non mais tu
vois si on mettait pas cette moyenne à
l'eau ça ça rendrait la compétition
complètement inintéressante mais je
pense ce même eux ils ont même pas envie
d'être ensemble je pense
c'est une sorte de c'est 2550 c'est une
sorte de fair-play financier
ou tu sais quand il y a un objectif en
commun les gens
il s'arrange enfin il s'arrange il se
bon ça va en plus je pense pas qu'il je
pense qu'il y a une certaine forme de de
respect
je disais dans le sens qui sont un peu
compétitifs tu vois et que du coup si il
se met tous ensemble ça pas intérêt et
même eux en fait pour eux
parce qu'ils sont enfin je sais pas
comme ça mais
pourquoi une femme en moi que c'est
bizarre que les hommes une femme vaut
pas moi une femme
en général il se trouve que voilà les
les hommes ont plus de classement en
tout cas les meilleurs joueurs du monde
ont plus de classement que les meilleurs
joueuses du monde après c'est évidemment
très varié et donc voilà la meilleure
chose du monde à 2600 je sais pas 50
quelque chose comme ça tandis que Maggie
a le meilleur joueur du monde à 2850
donc à peu près 200 points de plus donc
voilà c'est des règles pour inciter
justement et d'ailleurs c'est c'est
super c'est toi un mix et on voit
d'ailleurs Joséphine qui n'aurait jamais
eu l'occasion rien que de jouer contre
les Karuna Camara déjà il faut avoir
l'occasion de jouer contre la Camorra et
bien elle a pris sa chance
il y a 600
600 ouais 600 ouais quasiment 500 oui
c'est ça ouais donc déjà avoir
l'occasion de jouer et en plus et en
plus elle l'a battu c'est énorme
et franchement tu vois déjà la 3 1 pour
pour les berz et donc avec la belle
victoire de Joséphine Neyman et
maintenant on va voir un petit peu si sa
victoire vraiment
ça a quelque chose tu vois c'est
vraiment révélateur un peu dans le dans
ce dans ce match
on sait que l'équipe de NACA était quand
même largement favorite favori favorite
favorite je parle plus français
maintenant la maison et du coup des fois
ça m'arrive c'est ça m'arrive souvent
que je
sache plus conjuguer des trucs ou quoi
je pense plus espagnol que français le
soleil
quand on parle toute la journée
ouais c'est sûr on commence à réfléchir
du coup alors est-ce qu'on a est-ce
qu'ils ont commencé là parce qu'ils ont
la Focus je vois pas du tout les coups
je sais pas ce que tu as est-ce que tu
vois est-ce que tu vois quelque chose
alors
c'est vraiment assez extraordinaire ce
truc je sais pas comment faire pour
avoir vraiment les parties il faut que
tu ailles
ok
d'accord on a la caméra face à
c'est vrai que ça vient ouais
pardon c'est de ma faute
bon ben on joue une attaque est indienne
marrante sur sur V5
si tu connais ouais
et
j'étais 4
je pense déjà été joué seulement là il y
a un piège que je place tout le temps
sur internet c'est sur C4 avec les Noirs
faut jouer à 4 et dans cette position
sur la 4 il y a un seul coup pour les
noirs et le coup il est introuvable
enfin introuvable bien sûr qu'il est
trouvable mais en fois si je crois pas
je sais pas ce qu'il y a parfois 6 mais
d'accord
[Musique]
mais le seul coup c'est fou F5 en fait
tu connais pas bien que non ça peut vite
être compliqué ouais donc c'est
intéressant ce pion prend des 5 mais bon
il décide de jouer dans le style est
indien à ta question et voilà à
l'ancienne
ça marche pas ce truc là c'est que les
Noirs arrivent notamment avec l'apport
des ordinateurs les Noirs ont réussi à
quand même trouver des méthodes de
défense notamment ce h6f8
c'est quand même connu pour bien tenir
la route pour les Noirs alors là
peut-être j'ai 5 qui arrivent c'est vrai
que ça fait toujours peur ça fait
toujours peur mais avec l'ordi ça tient
pas mais après ça reste ça reste une
partie rapide donc
effectivement il peut un peu tout se
passer on a aussi Joséphine
face à l'écouen gliam on va voir
maintenant énorme suspense sur les
caméras je vais essayer de
énorme suspense qui n'a pas duré
longtemps et
les
convient il est là mais par contre
je ne fais pas confiance
puis on prend qu'elle va les prendre des
cas normalement on fait plutôt on fait
plutôt le 4 ici mais bon T4 normalement
c'est vraiment pas grand chose
ouais Joséphine qui connaît ces trucs
[Musique]
j'aime bien aussi parce que tu vois un
truc comme ça si tu faisais genre coup
de développement normal ça peut aller
très vite ces histoires comme ça tourne
cavalier qui traîne ça fait pas ça
bien sûr et donc dans le cadre pas mal
j'aime bien proposer une petite finale
il faut F4
échange refuse l'échange et du coup
on est persistant non
tu vas aller là vraiment pour échanger
peut-être
faut calculer ça en fait toujours mais
je crois que c'est bien pour
ces temps là je sais pas ce que ça donne
ça alors
c'est pas du tout forcé évidemment
d'ailleurs a été joué qui est C6 a été
joué par Joséphine et c'est pas mal
j'aime bien ok c'est 6 qui crée des qui
créent des embrouilles par exemple sur
Cai des deux on pourrait faire dame
prangers
5 et on récupère on récupère la dame on
est on est bien bon là on gagne pas de
pièces mais on est quand même très bien
et la paire de fou avec les Noirs donc
et c'est 6 ben film en jouet une fois de
plus en plus je défends au 7 donc par
rapport à ce qu'on avait vu avant que la
variante du cavalier les six qui partent
de partout bah écoute au final je
défends un peu tout
et puis vis-à-vis des fous gaz blanches
il est un peu disparu donc du coup
[Rires]
là ça y est ben oui effectivement tu me
donnes encore ça ça met en confiance ça
c'est sûr alors franchement franchement
là elle sait que son match est fait quoi
on va ouais on va découvrir wood World
alors à quoi il ressemble je vais
essayer de vous le mettre à la caméra
avec un peu de chance on va voir
apparaître vous de voir et oui magie de
l'internet contre
race muse vane que je vais trouver de ce
pas et voilà ça marche bien
équilibré je vous avais dit ça bouge pas
regarde c'est clair
[Musique]
d'être un espoir américain
unakamura et il a 13 ans il a 13 ans
regardez à 13 ans c'est formidable quand
même
il a 13 ans
et ouais
depuis un an déjà
remonter l'analyse sociologique de notre
ami je n'arrive pas à voir son nom sur
twitch
il se logique qui
n'engage que notre ami
alors
on va on va voir n'hésitez pas à poser
vos questions à faire vos remarques tant
que c'est dans le respect de chacun je
crois qu'il y a pas de je crois que
c'est ça l'esprit on est d'accord ouais
non après après c'est un débat depuis tu
vois mais bon toujours elle regrette
tout ça je crois que tous les joueurs
d'échec on aimerait voir plus de
joueuses et que ça soit plus équilibré
tu auras des chèques c'est toujours plus
sympa mais effectivement c'est pas ça se
fait pas du jour au lendemain je sais
pas même la solution
il y a beaucoup moins de joueuses c'est
clair après on parle l'histoire des
échecs il y a eu l'épaule gare il y a
aussi
mais bon après
c'est un débat que tu vois il y a plein
d'études là dessus on a on n'a pas la
réponse je pense pas que ce soit qu'un
fait qu'elles font le ménage
mais bon il y a beaucoup de monde tu
vois même juste pour l'instant dans le
top 100 mondial il y a qu'une femme quoi
ouais donc en tout cas clairement elles
ont
elles ont montré notamment à travers
elles ont montré que bon ben voilà quand
elles sont un entraînement
quand même de très haut niveau comme
comme a pu avoir Judith et attalard hors
du commun et bien elle était elle a fait
jouer candidat quasi
à jouer pour le titre de champion du
monde de champion de champion du monde
tout catégorie tout tout genre tout
genre confondu donc voilà il y a pas de
raison et un jour un jour ça arrivera
ce qu'on sera là pour le voir c'est ça
la question on espère en tout cas
parce que effectivement moi je trouve
que c'est ton un féminin finalement font
que voilà on voit que les meilleurs
joueurs se frotent finalement c'est pas
parce qu'elle joue entre femmes c'est
parce qu'elle joue finalement avec des
joueuses un peu moins fortes et donc en
fait ça cercle vicieux qui fait que on
fait moins de progrès en jouant des
joueurs moins fort moins bien classé
tout simplement
donc cahier des trois A4 joué par wood
Wars il s'en sort bien
contre Sven qui a joué à plus de 2600
un peu faible mais bon tu vois va être
faible aussi
donc
[Musique]
ça devient très concret
admettons je prends tu fais quoi
tu prends la tour je prends je suis
confort je crois ouais
bah tu prends ce qui était bon je me dis
peut-être que je peux piquer
c'est pas très beau quand même
je peux faire ça par exemple
non mais je fais pas ça alors finalement
je sais pas ce que je gagne non non pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout
donc sur le long terme ça va ouais ça va
ça menace de liquider et il a joué qui
est 4 raspbus West pour garder le pion à
3 c'est assez bien vu puis on prend les
trois tours en V3 et roi G7 ok bon ça
reste à peu près équilibré vous de voir
ce qui s'en sort très bien
on va voir Naka est-ce qu'il en est où
notre ami d'accord
on a une belle partie on va regarder
mais les deux joueurs clairement le plan
des Noirs c'est d'attaquer vers les
dames et le plan des blancs c'est de
faire all in alléluia
mais alors normalement à quoi que j'ai
l'impression que les noirs sont quand
même bien avancés
quand même il se prend avec en plus il
se prend des tactiques où on l'a perdu
on a perdu on va voir sa tête
il est extraordinaire contre notre ami
Sven Frédéric Zayn qu'on va montrer tout
de suite à l'écran et qui est là notre
ami oula il croit fond il est chaud il
est chaud voilà c'est bon ça et pourquoi
il pouvait pas prendre de la dame
Stéphane
parce que la tour protège évidemment il
y a pas d'échec et après ensuite on
prend ici oh là là regardez-moi ça
ikaruna kamura qui s'est pris une
combine lui
[Musique]
et
il peut y avoir des thèmes là alors il
est bien
dans cette partie
le nombre de pions il a pas de plus donc
il va pas dans le pion assis
c'est pas si clair
j'ai dû compter peut-être 4 fois ah
quand tu prends un pion plus excuse-moi
je comprends pas
donc là quand je prends à deux j'ai un
peu en plus
oui c'est ça ouais oui
[Musique]
c'est bien joué on sent le il lâche pas
tu veux faire tout reprendre
[Musique]
le jeu parce que là dans cette avant
avant de prendre
[Musique]
mais le truc c'est que le truc que je
voulais dire c'est que la jauge regardez
elle montre un peu près équilibrée mais
franchement à jouer avec les Noirs c'est
beaucoup moins drôle là
parce qu'en fait même si tu as passé une
tactique tu as mangé un pion tout ça bah
en fait il y a toujours de l'attaque moi
je te ferai je crois
un coupure
et si je te fais un tour C1 je te dis
que ok tu veux manger avant faire
tourner
si tu veux me faire tourcer un moi je
vais peut-être pas manger oula et il a
pas l'air content oui effectivement il y
a
alors il a joué dans le même esprit il a
joué tous ces 8 direct ok c'est la même
idée peut-être mieux d'ailleurs parce
que sur ton prof on fait prend et
c'est vrai que ça fait pas de mal de
protéger espion et fous des quatre jours
ton prof il prend bon l'inconvénient
c'est qu'on peut pas prendre depuis en
deux parce qu'il y aurait E6 en l'air
donc il faut maintenant trouver une
solution pour ça
bienvenue
donc F4 peut-être alors il y a aussi ce
pion et c'est marrant cette position 19
secondes pour ce vaneux là je me fais je
me fais attraper par ciel F4 jouer x 6
puis on prend le 5 20 secondes contre
écaruna Camara c'est intenable c'est
trop dur à tenir là attention
il est super alors
ça sera pas mal et si je fais ça ça
il faut acheter
ça serait pas bête et méchant
c'est la partie et oui c'est le bah même
si maintenant en fait c'est pas grave
alors est-ce qu'on peut être intercalé
peut-être
manger manger essayer de pousser des
pions mais non ça va te perdre
qualité comme ça dans une position
ouverte c'est toujours c'est toujours
compliqué
donc il a joué ton C6 c'est fou F5 G6
évidemment que IKON Nakamura je sais pas
ce qu'il va prendre du pion de la tour
il a pris du pion rouge et sel qu'on
avait hein toi FC 3G 8
tu sais quoi je crois qu'on peut
encaisser une pièce ouais tu reprends
mes 7 tours français 5 fois 6 il va
faire tout F7 et G7 et il va abandonner
notre ami c'est pas fait déjà non H3
contrarones sauf pas cette partie contre
Caro Nakamura c'est gagné pour
icarbonate et premier point de la
journée certainement pas le dernier on
va voir qui on va voir Joséphine allez
fine ah mais Joséphine Joséphine ça se
passe moins bien d'un coup elle est
quand même c'est le client
c'est professionnel franchement il est
hyper serein quand tu le vois jouer
avant sur la caméra et tout il est hyper
sort quoi qui ça
le Kang alors on va le mettre les Kangs
il est hyper serein donc là je le vois
pas mais tout à l'heure
tu vois il est là tranquille il est
vraiment
il a une position un petit peu une
posture un petit peu bizarre il va la
gagner cette finale de Tours depuis le
mois finale de tour c'est un pion de
trop en moins si on a enlevé ce pion on
ferait nul mais le problème c'est que il
y a spion donc là on peut même faire
peut-être 6 doit gagner B7 il doit
gagner aussi bref
on fait à peu près ce qu'on veut
il est proche de la caméra
un peu trop
tu vois c'est le contraste avec avec le
Kang ça joue pas sa faveur quand ils
vont se jouer ça va être marrant
attends je regarde si c'est moi ou si
vraiment est-ce que j'ai mal cadré non
j'ai bien cadré
[Musique]
mais franchement c'est c'est pas loin de
ça bon en tout cas on voit bien alors
on en est où au niveau du
il est quand même bien
pourquoi je peux donc il y a plus de
temps il y a 19 sur une chacun et c'est
la dernière partie en cours évidemment
Nakamura les kanglame ont gagné tandis
qu'au bout de voir comment on l'avait
dit il a tenu la nulle face à Sven face
à vaneux Rasmus donc trois et demi de
demi dans cette portion pour ah non deux
et demi et demi mais apparemment
pour ça on va voir ce qui va se passer
ce qui va tomber à un moment donné
le
14 secondes en maths quand même comment
ouais mais c'est pas très c'est pas le
coup plus actif de la terre non non et
là c'est nul c'est pas bon du tout il y
a tout deux et mat à suivre je l'ai pas
vu
elle a gagné pour ça et regardez-moi
cette gaffe comme quoi au plus haut
niveau
tu vois encore une fois ça serait la
manque de temps tu vois ils avaient tous
les 10 secondes à la pendule et ça ça
blender regardez
et parce que tour 2 et en plus on est on
est très passif évidemment avec les
blancs mais on a cette dame volante qui
va faire des misères au roi noir qui a
menacé des pères pêches
j'ai une tour de moi qui joue pas quoi
mais je pense que je veux si je fais ça
tu vois oui oui d'ailleurs
je pense énormément
incroyable incroyable bah oui
en fait un échec de consolation
enfin on peut en faire 12 des échecs
peut-être pas 12 secondes en enfer on en
fait quelques heures mais voilà un
ordinateur jouer ça mais ça arrange pas
les affaires on peut toujours pas pareil
le matin un coup en G2 et ça fait trois
et demi-heure et demi pour cette portion
pour les Gotham Knights quel
retour des grâces grâce à Natalia ou que
ça
et franchement les femmes dans ce
tournoi franchement elles font le job
franchement
Joséphine qui a patinata et là on voit
Natalia bouqua qui bat collarse et c'est
deux résultats quand même qui sont assez
surprenants donc on voit tout est
possible avant ce match même les joueurs
qui sont les moins forts sur le papier
en fait sont capables là c'est ma tour
dedans ouais il a il a il a ses ciel
bleu qui proposait ça donc je voulais
lui montrer dame c'est cette dame G4
évidemment je peux apprendre de la dame
mais il y a tout reprend j'ai deux
suivis de où tu iras j'irai et c'est
Matt au prochain coup
bon très bien très bien très bien très
bien tout ça du coup quatre amis à 3 et
demi pour pour les Gotham Knights du
coup qui était menus qui était mené
trois avant ce match
et du coup qui prennent maintenant la
tête de de ce match alors
je vais te dire alors je suis attendre
que Nathan m'envoie la photo ah non non
pardon là j'avais tout là
alors du coup j'ai tout donc j'ai
rassemus blanc non excuse-moi je te dis
n'importe quoi
ça a commencé à être compliqué vas-y je
le vois je le vois à gauche donc je
pense qu'en fait non il y a un truc noir
en plus
ils ont le même nom quand même tu es
quand même faut avoir la poisse les gens
maintenant en plus alors vas-y lequel
race plus non mais reste plus
apparemment ils sont frère
il est blanc
il aura les Noirs contre le
Kangui du coup
je vous fais en direct l'écran les Kong
il est je vais pas le faire direct voilà
je vous laisse comme ça et comme ça vous
pouvez observer les joueurs pendant que
je fais tout ça donc les coins de la
salle de vie ça commence à être vraiment
Stéphane les appareillesment
archi serré quoi c'est-à-dire les
meilleurs joueurs comme ça ce jouet
[Musique]
ok super donc ça c'est bon ensuite
et
Colars non encore une fois je me trompe
Nakamura
il faudrait qu'il se décale sa caméra
quand même ça ça
va pas ok d'accord
contrecolarse ok et au troisième
échiquier nous aurons donc on a Frédéric
zeane
Natalia bouxa
qui est a été simplement l'héroïne de la
de la ronde précédente
ça fait plaisir
et contre Nathalie
qu'elle est blanche qui joue à contre
Andy
le jeune prodige de 13 ans qui est déjà
mettre international
il a fait une partie vraiment ultra
solide
face
à un joueur comme à 2006 qui est qui est
quand même
très connu et déjà
[Musique]
ça veut dire que
américain Got Talent qu'est-ce que je
vous dise
salut à tous ceux qui arrivent
salut salut
à vous je fais des petits des petits
réglages comme ça on est bien ben voilà
je crois qu'on est au top il a les
blancs on est d'accord
Andy alors attends j'avais enlevé
Andy elle est noire on dit elle est
noire
c'est bon en fait je suis surpris quand
ils sont bons endroits donc j'étais un
seul échanger bon allez on revient on
revient ça va être on va commencer par
les carbonakaora qui aura donc qui aura
donc les blancs face à notre ami
svaneux Rasmus
vaneux qui va être là sous vos yeux
ébahis qui apparaît et bon ben voilà
attention joueur très très dangereux
très solide donc Naka va pas fort qu'il
fasse n'importe quoi comme à la partie
précédente
ouais bon là encore c'était burtle line
d'accord
mais tu vois il joue vraiment en mode
freestyle string il fait un petit peu le
tu vois le le show quoi donc là un aka
attention il peut il peut se prendre il
peut se prendre une petite caisse
ça peut être très chaud
bon je vois que sa chambre dans le chat
mais bon allez réglages sont au top ce
soir on se moque de moi mais bon ça va
je le prends avec le sourire je fais ce
que je peux on rappelle que on est
partout Stéphane on est sur cheesecom
Youtube
en français chaise 24 en français on
vous invitait évidemment à vous abonner
surtout à la chaîne cheesecom en
français parce que c'est là où tout se
passera évidemment la chaîne chaise 24
en français n'a pas vocation à
disparaître mais là comme vous avez pu
remarquer si vous êtes abonné là la
cadence c'est quand même
c'est quand même ralenti ces derniers
mois donc voilà et donc n'hésitez pas à
venir sur chaisecom à vous abonner à la
chaîne et comme ça vous recevez un petit
mail et c'est sympa les petits mails
comme ça voilà ça vous dit il y a un
live après vous êtes dispo vous regardez
il y a pas vous êtes pas dispo regardez
pas c'est aussi un peu comme ça donc un
petit coucou à tout le monde d'ailleurs
pour pour ceux qui sont sur Youtube et
sur pour ceux qui nous regardent depuis
YouTube ou pour qui sont qui nous
suivent même sur sur chaise 24 ou
cheescom twitch tout ça n'hésitez pas à
venir vous abonner à la chaîne Youtube
c'est gratuit c'est cool et puis il y a
plein de contenu qui va arriver très
bientôt sur sur Youtube donc donc voilà
si quoi comme contenu est-ce que tu peux
nous dire ou c'est une surprise
des vidéos qui vont arriver
j'ai commencé à faire quelques-unes déjà
mais est-ce que ah d'accord c'est génial
parce qu'en fait est-ce que tu regardes
c'est pour savoir c'est un test vieux
c'est le quiz vieux est-ce que ça
t'arrive de rater du replay sur twitch
[Musique]
moi franchement le le replay bon
j'allais dire 90% mais en fait c'est pas
vrai 0 % sur twitch de Replay et 100%
sur Youtube si j'ai envie de regarder un
truc mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
c'est un peu non
après moi je suis plus twitch que
YouTube de base d'accord
mais c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
un c'est aussi un peu la génération
parce que parce que Youtube c'est quand
même plus vieux il y a beaucoup de monde
qui sont plus à l'aise sur Youtube tu
vois d'accord
je cherchais on est d'accord on est
d'accord j'ai cherché mais quand même
parce que c'est fou il y a plein de gens
même tu vois autour de moi des fois
quand je parle aux gens je leur dis que
je fais le stream sur twitch il me dit
mais c'est quoi twitch il y a plein
plein et des gens qui ont 30 ans tu vois
35 ans 40 ans et en fait et en fait ben
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose de
d'assez nouveau quoi
bon en tout cas où vous voulez mais
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce et à
soutenir évidemment tout ce qui est fait
sur cette chaîne j'ai vu les stats de
Youtube c'est assez hallucinant c'est
vrai que c'est maintenant qu'il me
l'avait dit qu'apparemment 71% des
viewers YouTube sont pas abonnés à la
chaîne ce qui est énorme il m'a demandé
quels étaient les stats pour 13 24 fr à
l'époque et c'est pareil 72% et
d'ailleurs on mettait un petit en mettez
un petit mot à la fin en disant 72%
d'entre vous ne sont pas ne sont pas
abonnés donc allez-y abonnez-vous comme
ça voilà on rate pas et puis on est
content
ça laisse le choix en fait de regarder
ou de pas regarder voilà ça prend 5
secondes et
intéressé tu vas recevoir des notifs dès
qu'il y a un truc si tu es abonné sur
Youtube tu vas recevoir à chaque fois un
petit moi sur mon téléphone j'ai un
genre soit c'est ça un petit truc qui a
une vidéo de d'un tel
sur twitch quand tu es en ligne et ben
tu le reçois après tu peux me désactiver
si tu veux notification mais au moins tu
es tu es un truc du coup c'est cool quoi
et en plus elle nous aide donc en fait
ben je sais pas c'est juste bien quoi
donc
abonnez-vous quoi
mettez des pouces bleus aussi parce
qu'en fait le replay c'est ce que j'ai
appris je savais pas mais en fait ton
de pouce bleu sur la vidéo plus
ton replay il est mis en avant dans
YouTube ok bah les pouces bleus à chaque
fois des pouces bleus des pouces bleus
donc voilà ça je savais aussi mais bon
tu vois ça nous aide aussi
donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas les
commentaires voilà j'avais déjà tout le
monde sauf moi s'il vous plaît moi ça me
je pleure à chaque commentaire négatif
sur Youtube donc s'il vous plaît soyez
gentil donc que du positif alors ces
quatre six et une catalane de la part de
les conglihem
contre vaneux on va voir fossette et
ouais faut sept il a une tête à jouer
s'il y a des gens comme ça voilà ça ça
va être pour les gens comme moi et les
gens comme moi trouvent ça passionnant
déjà comme toi trouve ça très
certainement peut-être un peu
c'est quand même mis
donc du coup c'est vrai que ça
après moi je trouve intéressant mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas le truc qui me
qui me botte le plus on va être honnête
bon on va être honnête aussi les Noirs
jouent avant de la plus solide qui
existe avec le foin E7 ici évidemment
inspiré comme tu l'as dit Magnus Carlson
qui est préparé ça pour son dernier
match champion du monde face à Yann les
premiers inspiré en grande partie
évidemment pas le
l'imaginatif Daniel du bof qui est un
expert de la Catalane depuis de
nombreuses années il se sent pas bien si
la peinture de moi en gros Daniel
magnifique l'immortel il lui fait des
belles parties à gay en fait il fait un
truc qu'on guérit parce que guéri est
toujours un petit peu
il aime pas il aime pas se faire
attaquer et tout ça et donc en fait il
double prend mais cette prise de risque
à son paroxysme qu'on me guérit et il
sait très bien que guéri il se sent pas
confortable dans ce genre de situation
et en fait mais il le fait vraiment en
prenant des risques incroyables et c'est
contre guéri ça marche très très bien en
partie rapide et un très très gros score
contre gay
donc voilà Daniel duboff n'hésitez pas à
regarder c'est parti parce qu'il en fait
des balles je sais pas si tu as vu celle
qu'on a qu'une que j'avais d'ailleurs
commenté j'avais analysé pour la chaîne
Youtube en français aller voir dove
caryaki il y a une demi-heure d'analyse
où je me suis fait plaisir et
franchement c'est une des
c'est très très beau ce qu'il fait c'est
du grand art c'est du semi bluff hein
mais parce qu'elle ne marche pas du tout
ça mais bon en plus si il a enfin ces
trucs il est pas totalement
slips pas mais il sait très bien que
c'est pas bon mais il espère surprendre
et voilà
et il est très fort pour ça il est très
fort pour juger si ça va être si c'est
trop risqué ou pas et donc
c'est un genre qu'on aime beaucoup donc
roi prangers de C6 bon les blancs sont
un petit peu mieux on a le centre mais
l'avantage des Noirs c'est qu'on a
absolument aucune faiblesse dans cette
position on a toujours une belle case
ici on va pouvoir jouer dame B6 parfois
damassis on va essayer de mettre des
tours par là on sait très compliqué pour
les blancs de progresser mais c'est
quand même plus agréable à jouer parce
que on a un très beau centre les pièces
derrière une dame bien centralisée un
cavalier très bien placé on a des belles
pièces mais pas pas de faiblesse pour le
noir
donc voilà je sais pas tu préfères les
blancs tu es d'accord
je suis en train avec toi
c'est clair que c'est plus plaisant pour
les blancs
mais c'est une position qui a l'air
assez connue pour les deux joueurs de
toute façon ouais clairement
mais les gangs comme tu l'as dit le
physique enfin en tout cas physiquement
on voit il est très tranquille il joue
pareil
il joue pareil sur échiquier est-ce que
les autres ont commencé ou pas
on voit à part le à part le dernier
échiquier
ça vient de te lancer à peine on va on
va on va voir
monsieur
donc là il y a eu voilà Monsieur front
monsieur front donc on voit
ces trois pour empêcher carrer des
quatre
pardon ouais normalement ça donne rien
du tout cette ligne il faut vraiment sa
main
la Canon F6 et ouais donc là on fait pas
on pourrait pas attention on n'a pas on
va surtout pas envie que les Noirs
fassent en route donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils jouent 3 ici pour ce qui est
notre moyen de gagner avec moyen de
défendre
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là ce qu'on donne
le fou est-ce que tu recules ton four
le fouet
il faut venir chercher les fous donc je
fais ça
j'aime pas j'aime pas échanger
[Musique]
si je mets à ça ou pas c'est pas mon
histoire et je vais jouer grand rock au
prochain coup
en espérant que tu décides que je menace
ça en fait
ok peut-être qu'il veut juste venir en
C4
peut-être aussi
moi je pense qu'il espère en fait je
pense qu'il espère que j'ai cinq fous
des 7 et comme ça après il peut faire H6
ce cavalier tu as perdu un temps
finalement
c'est 4K 3 bon tu viens de détente mais
j'en sais rien peut-être bon bref les
deux il a fait pas grand rock ça ça
m'étonne maintenant peut-être il a deux
fois
qui empêche qui met une pression sur le
cavalier ce fou qui est mauvais une fois
que tu as joué 5 en fait c'est un
mauvais jeu
donc intéressant pas mal du tout
j'aime bien
est-ce que je peux jouer non je vais
dire une grosse bêtise ton voisin qui
réfléchit
il fait le show regarde
le ciel voir s'il a la réponse il fait
ça pendant les parties normales aussi
donc là c'est pareil
[Musique]
il le joue parce qu'il sait qu'on le
regarde en fait il joue son petit qui
fait son petit show quoi
mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait la tourte
c'est un couple mais je pense à faire
des trous fins et tous ces quatre
je crois que ton c'est pas mal de se
découle quand même ou alors faut B2
ouais j'ai peur
parce que
je sais pas j'aime pas trop mais bon
c'est vrai que tu déclen aussi en même
temps peut-être fou B2 pour essayer de
se protéger au moins avoir ça de
protéger parce que la tension est nulle
à se directe ça c'est pas là ça rigole
plus maintenant qu'elle prend 4 et
clairement une menace
donc comment on va faire la position
c'est bizarre
sont clairement pas mieux et
objectivement on prendrait les Noirs je
crois
d'accord
mon fond en G2 le fond ancien j'ai un
problème alors est-ce que je peux pas
faire ça
le
moi je prends un pion j'ai protégé ce
pion alors je suis toujours cloué mais
on va on va mourir le ventre plein déjà
pas mal
[Musique]
donc on a une case pas très agréable à
la cavalier H5 mais bon on n'a pas envie
de faire ça
ok je sais pas il va nous dire ICO il a
pas du tout jouer ça il a joué B2
[Musique]
cette qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire il va
aller là il va aller là
mais quoi c'est responsable je joue F6
pour bien défendre 5 non je fais plus
mais ça c'est pour prendre le pion mais
là non et il fait à 4 Hikaru donc ok il
veut déjà empêcher que la 4 et sur kb6
il aura toujours à 5 donc ça c'est un
bon bruit prendre de l'espace pour pas
cher
est-ce que je peux jouer à ça
c'est légal
parce que c'est bon j'en ai absolument
aucune idée donc je pousse à priori
parce que quoi d'autre
tu vas où tu me fais tu me fais le
circuit des cavaliers
tu as un petit problème tu as pas envie
de
un petit peu
il a joué qui est CB8 le joueur le grand
maître allemand
il veut faire il veut faire ça et
surtout à trois peut-être fois 8
et ensuite ton coup de F6 et F6 direct
d'ailleurs il y a pas le feu
et ensuite il faut vite
et si c'est le point qui va arriver
pour l'instant tu as ça en prise
peut-être que faux à 3 va être un coup
on est en train de trouver tous les
coups là quand même
on va jouer
évidemment il joue comme nous quoi les
joueurs
5 mais on n'a pas envie de jouer F5 pour
protéger ici et le Cavalaire dans ces
structures malheureusement bien contre
pions eux ils jouent pas tout simplement
donc cavalier B8 a beaucoup de sens pour
installer un éventuel relais par exemple
on pourra aller ramasser spion en
instant en installant un relais de
cavaliers donc ça a beaucoup de sens qui
fait le grand maître allemand je sais
pas si c'est bon ou pas moi d'après la
chose c'est quand même assez bon mais en
tout cas ça a du sens qui a essayé 4 B6
et ouais on protège tout de suite le
pion et maintenant ce pion c'est ça
l'avantage des Noirs c'est que ce pion
cette chaîne de pion est parfaite
c'est une faiblesse incroyable il faut à
trois c'est flacon
des blancs pour ensuite mettre le
cavalan C5 et le cavaler qui va être un
des loisirs il est pas bien il est pas
bien parce qu'en C5 c'est bingo hein je
t'attaque ici je t'attaque ici au moins
tu as provoqué B6 donc t'as pas l'autre
tu vas pas te tu vas pas te faire coller
l'autre cavalier en veux aussi c'est à
ce moment là tu paieras 4 quasiment sûr
ouais c'est subtil mais très très bon
jeu de la part de Colars attention ce
qu'est le match alors et tu sais voilà
je sais pas
en forme
et ben écoute je te présente
mes prises prises cavalier C5
mais non je crois qu'il y a pour
l'instant là tu peux pas
chaud je vais faire quoi alors
c'est un peu la crise
il veut jouer
qu'est-ce qu'il y a son chat
tu sais à son chat
tu sais qu'est-ce qu'il y a son chat
je sais pas ce qu'il y a son chat mais
bon
c'est pas beau c'est peut-être
nécessaire on a tellement envie de ce
qu'il veut faire
doubler par cœur
et en même temps
c'est quand même formidable joueur
pratiqué et qui a été de tour des 7 je
te donne en mille C4 à tempo pour faire
cailler des 5 et bloquer coûte que coûte
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire il y a pas
le choix
est-ce que alors dis-moi j'ai un quoi
proposer qui a l'air dégueulasse mais
est-ce que c'est un coup
alors c'est si j'aime pas empêcher que
je me dis que si tu prends chez Kama des
tronc et tu sais que je mange et je me
cavalier
[Musique]
mais je sais pas c'est mon groupe
personnel
j'aurais fait plutôt ça moi mais bon
pour un filtrer la tour et menacée de
prendre mais il a joué tourage D8 bon
mais ça a l'air pas mal cahier des cinq
il fait F5
mais écoute pour l'instant moi la partie
de colère je la signa avec plaisir
[Musique]
encore une fois sans prendre alors du
coup
et ensuite on reprend et on fait ça mais
j'ai pas j'aime pas trop mais bon après
comment on progresse sinon
tu pointes du doigt un problème qui va
être dans cette position c'est à dire
comment les Noirs intensifient leur
pression alors les Blancs ont du mal à
bouger quand même tu vois la tour à
trois elle défend pion à 4 là il va me
dire
que le roi B7
pour ramener cavalier en 17 F6 voir ce
qui se passe déjà ouais ouais ça me fait
bien ouais parce que c'est vrai qu'avec
les blancs en fait ils vont attendre
tout simplement parce qu'ils peuvent
améliorer la pollution parce que ce
cavaler en des deux
il défend enfin il défend aussi depuis
le 4 tout ça
parfois pendant les parties de rêver de
tu fermes les yeux tu sais tu dis ou
est-ce que j'aimerais mon cavalier
il va jouer alors
c'est trois et après la tour sera
libérée il est malin comme tout il car
on a qu'à Moura
c'est un diable
et on a deux résultats un books
j'aurais voulu bouger mon jeu cavaler E6
et cavaler des cartes mais l'autre
cavalier en C5
et mettre l'autre clé en éclate
[Musique]
mais effectivement
parce que là
j'aime bien comment il joue Collard il
joue simple il joue vite aussi il
contrôle la pendule ils sont ils sont
égalité autant qu'on a qu'à c'est pas
tous les jours parce qu'il joue il joue
quand même très très vite
qu'est-ce que tu penses de jouer regarde
de jouer voilà ça va être compliqué
je pensais je pensais roi B8 pour que je
cavaler B7 qui avait les DC c'est
maintenant de cavalier en C5 on est en
train de marrer et moi je veux mais en
plus et lui en fait il me lui donne lui
double sur un seul que nous ouverte
quelle marque d'imagination ton plan est
beaucoup plus imaginatif mais c'est vrai
que j'aime beaucoup la façon dont il
gère cette partie parce que il joue vite
tu vois et le meilleur moyen de de
perdre c'est de ces distances c'est
autant et de se faire avoir dans le
Night donc moi c'est un diable donc faut
jouer vite faut tenir la pendule faut
croire
ce qui peut arriver
il revient il fait tout
pour deux F7 et C4 tu as raison je crois
qu'il va faire des six
même avant peut-être
et regarde ça c'est hyper bien joué de
la part de colours chantage à la nul la
cave veut la gagner à fond alors là je
te fais je te fais une grosse cote je
suis sûr que nakan ne prend pas la
mienne voilà
je suis ma main regardez
je la mets ici on la coupe en direct non
non on la coupe en direct si si en
direct
sur
100% qui fait pas nul
je pense qu'il va la jouer
il souffle j'adore attention attention
c'est pas très sympa
oui j'ai déjà perdu ma main gauche dans
un stream il y a longtemps
c'est un coup car ça n'a pas joué
effectivement mais alors là c'est la
main droite c'est pas pareil ça n'a rien
à voir
pour la droitier tu vois c'est plus
utile
on va voir est-ce que il se passe
quelque chose d'intéressant sur les
autres de chez qui est-ce que tu as un
truc à voir et regarder il a joué full
F3 Nakamura G2 et voilà la main droite
qui reste c'est beau
cavalier 8 oh ça y est enfin ah bah
voilà tu vois il a pas compris ton
recette il va faire mais un jour je
n'aime pas du tout
un moment donné il fallait
prises qu'elle va le prendre pour
prendre peut-être
qui est pas terrible
[Musique]
non tu reprends des 6 cette position on
l'a et là c'est
encore n'importe quoi
c'est pas bon du tout
c'est pas bon du tout j'ai eu on
comprend pas
je porte pas mais on va voir un peu
je pense que le match lesquels un peu
déséquilibré dans le sens comme devant
ma 2 gros leaders avec NACA et le Kang
[Musique]
je sais pas pour l'instant on était
surpris quand même dans les deux matchs
par contre la technique mon cher Kévin
est très très au point je sais pas qui
s'en est occupé c'est assez incroyable
ce qui se passe ce soir
donc
les dernières fois mais là aujourd'hui
ça se passe vraiment ça se passe
beaucoup mieux que les dernières fois
que Nathan qui s'est passé encore un
petit quart d'heure
je sais pas j'ai tapé un coup dans
l'ordi ça a marché après mais avec tes
deux fois c'est c'est il y a pas il y a
pas de non quoi juste
alors on va faire ça non non je
progresse chaque jour tu sais Kevin
c'est ça c'est on part de très bas et on
progresse chaque jour un petit peu très
important de progresser un petit échec
là-bas qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ça peut être chiant mais après je m'en
fous qui sort peut-être fou c'est 4
mais ça marchera pas je pense c'est vrai
il faut que tu fasses vite là en fait il
a joué quoi je t'aurais fait un H5 food
tout simplement ah il va aller là il est
malin comme tout mais du coup on descend
comme ça
ok ouais comme ça aussi
et si tu bouges si tu protèges je vais
faire tour F6 et là
tu te fais tout manger et il a fait quoi
c'est quoi la
il a fait tout rêve 6 ouais la même idée
et là attention les yeux il est foutu ah
il avait fait une belle partie Collard
mais là il est fort d'accord
quand même pas sa position c'est une
sacrée forêt il a retourné en deux trois
mouvements
bravo en fait
c'est dur aussi des fois
de vraiment bien finir quoi
bonprise pour résiste
il faut qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
pourquoi il veut pas faire j'ai pas
compris
la petite catalane avait il a pris il a
fait un point donc ils prennent de l'art
et Andy Woodward a fait nul contre
Joséphine a une Mann un bon résultat
mais attention et car on a qu'à moi va
l'emporter là on aura un dernier match
mais malheureusement il faut que cela
gagne contre boxa sinon il y a aucun
suspense dans le dernier match déjà le
suspense sera limité
[Musique]
il va pas laisser passer sa chance c'est
une évidence
[Musique]
un petit pion passé ok la pendule contre
20 secondes je pense qu'il va gagner ce
Brahim on espère pour le suspense on a
rien contre contre boxer mais bon
bien au contraire
mais là le roi va venir moi j'ai deux
rouages 3 ouais
faudrait quand même garder garder le
suspense pour le dernier match cette
même 7,5 franchement
7,5 avec Nakamura et Nakamura a gagné
tu peux aller voir c'est pas terminant
encore mais attends il a gagné alors
on a le on a le score mais il fait roi
j'ai 3 ans
et il vient là c'est terminé OK
[Musique]
apparemment notez la boxa ouais du coup
score
et ça fait du coup 7,5 du coup 7,5 ok
bah c'est comme tout à l'heure avec avec
blindstream qui jouait contre les petits
indiens là ils ont pas ils ont pas
grichou qui est Maxime machin dans
l'équipe
de Berlin qui joue bien le coup ils sont
très solides mais quand même
la femme parce que du coup il y a 7,5
pour les pour les Gotham Knights et
quand on voit la pareillement de la
dernière ronde et ben du coup tu as
enfin il faut qu'il fasse plus de sur le
match dans gagner au moins 3-1 tu vois
et quand tu vois un pareillement tu vois
rassemus Vennes avec les Blancs contre
Naka
bon je passe quelque chose mais je vois
mal quand même
on va faire ça j'essaie de trouver
ouais évidemment que veine il va pas
être favori j'ai fait n'importe quoi
je pense que le meilleur la meilleure
chance pour qu'il gagne ce match les
Allemands c'est qu'ils arrivent à tenir
devant ils ont les blancs deux fois mais
bon même si même Naka le Kang et après
les échiquiers tu vois le troisième
échiquier
ensuite il a quoi à l'école en fait
c'est noir noir à chaque fois donc Naka
noir le camp noir contre Colars
vraiment
ok contre collars et oui que notre ami
Colars donc il y aura les blancs
tout à fait tout à fait il y aura les
blancs et qu'on va mettre là Monsieur
monsieur trop près et ensuite au 3 on
aura
on aura donc Frédéric vaneux alors
[Rires]
je vous parle je fais mes petits
réglages évidemment j'ai la guigne à
chaque fois le type est du mauvais côté
mais en même temps les mecs alternent la
couleur donc faut pas s'étonner d'avoir
la Guinée non plus c'est pas vraiment
une histoire de guigne intégrale quoi tu
vois c'est à dire qu'il en fait il
change de couleur comme des gens normaux
contre contre il jouera contre eux
ça il peut ils peuvent gagner quand même
non tu en penses après on va voir mais
disons qu'au dernier bon ben c'est 2000
francs en 2004 c'est assez ouvert
en plus Joséphine pour l'instant on a
fait elle a fait un très bon match
et ensuite on a fait un on a donc
Joséphine elle est blanc et noir
contre Natalia bougsa j'aurais préféré
j'aurais préféré qu'elle est blanc tu
vois marrant
mais bon
donc on va faire ça et la télé booksa
donc la joueuse ukrainienne
qui qui a combien de points on va on va
regarder peut-être les scores des
joueurs
[Musique]
qui est là
elle est donc elle a les blancs
ok bah écoute ça devrait être pas mal on
va faire ça et on va regarder peut-être
des scores ce que j'ai score individuel
et bien oui j'ai ce qu'on individuel et
regardez-moi ça ok
ce qui a fait une bonne partie quand on
a Camara mais un sur trois Frédéric
svaneux un sur trois aussi et un demi
sur trois pour jouer une Mann qui sait
au faire le scalp de de de Nico Nakamura
et oui le meilleur joueur de Blitz on a
une par contre les congames le métronome
3 sur 3 impressionnant
Ikao Nakamura qui évidemment revenu de
sur trois il n'y a que la boxer Woodward
qui marque alors 1 sur 3 certes c'est
pas énorme mais c'est les différences de
deux points donc heureusement qu'ils
sont là aussi c'est clair on va moi ce
que je te propose Stéphane c'est de
faire un léger break et de revenir pour
cette dernière onde ça marche voilà et
on revient tout de suite merci de nous
suivre à tout de suite et à ce que tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes donc de retour pour une
dernière ronde des équilibrée mais bon
déséquilibré mais il y a que deux points
deux points à rattraper et puis vu les
appariement on a déjà donné tout à
l'heure on va leur donner si vous voulez
on aura
hikao qui est quand même depuis le début
du match qui est quand même borderline
il a deux points sur trois mais les
parties sont pas claires du tout tu vois
ils gagnent beaucoup de parties à
l'arracher
on a dit micolas ce qui joue contre le
camp qui lui a 3 sur 3 et il est hyper
en forme hyper serein calme tout ça donc
ça on va voir on a Frédéric Sven qui
joue contre Andy Woodward donc là Andy
wood Wars c'est un jeune américain qui a
13 ans 24,50 m dans l'arsenal donc c'est
un super joueur mais bon
on va dire parce que là on se fait huer
par le chat
très énervés donc on sait qu'il se
trouve derrière le pseudo de chasse
comme fr c'est
assez facile à deviner mais moi je
savais en plus j'ai honte tu sais que ça
fait ça fait j'ai commencé à jouer aussi
alors je dirais pas tiens ça fait Stella
au siècle dernier j'ai commencé à jouer
au bout de cigare et j'ai fait le
programme allemand je dise veine voilà
c'est ça ça résume les programmes
allemands donc c'est pas terrible
alors voilà et donc après on a
après svano
les couleurs c'était Natalia bouxa qui
joue contre Joséphine anmann donc c'est
les deux féminines du championnat enfin
de la requie qui jusque là en fait un
super un super tournoi Joséphine qui qui
s'est payé le luxe de battre Nakamura
première partie
donc grosse grosse perte
la perfe
peut-être d'une vie oui c'est ça
exactement c'est j'osais pas le dire tu
as tout à fait raison allez vu Nakamura
une fois je crois que c'est la ronde un
d'un
il avait une fille alors je sais plus du
tout qui c'était une fille à 2100 2002
d'accord et il était complètement foutu
il avait des trucs genre qualité de
pions de moins son roi qui s'était
baladé sur le chéquier et il avait gagné
la partie d'ailleurs j'ai un souvenir
dans ma tête je me demande si c'était
pas
Natacha c'est possible
je te promets dans ma tête maintenant
on rappelle que enfin pour ceux qui
demandent c'est possible le il y a 7 5
tout est possible bli blistribble l'a
fait et à gagner ensuite les départages
donc voilà l'équipe française
qui a gagné donc
et démantèle qui ont mis les deux points
et deux nuls chez Maël Boyer et Sacha
gré de chou qui est ensuite en blitz 2,5
donc une vis une victoire importante qui
compte autant que une victoire 8 et demi
donc voilà
victoire que tu peux faire c'est
important et là on voit maintenant tu
vois avec 7,5 qui a quand même eu des
des parties qui sont terminées pour la
première partie la partie de je crois
que c'était Frédéric vaneux qui a perdu
avec un mausleep contre
le gang et qui était pas prêt quand même
non d'accord mais bon j'ai 5 bon c'est
au lit quoi
[Musique]
ça joue à fond dans les raisons
la perdre un coup à cause du de la
souris là il y a 7,5 peut-être que ça
aurait pu changer un petit peu le score
même si bon il est vrai que est-ce que
tu me trouves d'être est-ce que tu me
trouves cruel d'être content de voir à
chaque fois que honnêtement je suis
hyper content
parce que ça ne m'est jamais arrivé je
mets toujours ce que j'expliquais tout à
l'heure je vais toujours vachement de
temps bon j'ai pas expliqué que j'étais
content mais en tout cas je donne pas de
taille bac ça c'est sûr mais en tout cas
le truc moi ça me fait toujours un petit
plaisir tous ces gens qui veulent aller
vite
voilà alors par contre je pense qu'il y
a certains qui vont être contents dans
le chat que j'ai une galère technique
cette page ne répond pas cette page ne
répond pas
j'en ai bien peur
je ferme et réouvre en mince enfin avant
d'affronter l'OM euh on est pas bien moi
je vous le dis
non técom
j'ai toutes les parties les gens qui ont
commencé
des parties qui ont commencé j'ai un bug
énorme ici
mais ça va venir ou pas
je comprends pas pourquoi
merci
j'ai proposé d'utiliser Skype hier quand
même je tiens le signaler
j'ai utilisé ce CAP
et voilà bon j'étais content de mon
par contre
j'ai un énorme bug et oui ça ne durait
ça ne pourrait pas durer
j'ai un énorme bug
ça marche pas du tout c'est que pour moi
là attends moi ça marche
donc je sais pas
ah c'est moche
tu veux pas tu peux partager ton écran
dans le
ouais mais tu vas voir je t'avais dit
je vais essayer de trouver une autre
solution pour le coup
c'est ma caméra qui a
plus ouais non mais je voulais que tu me
partage dans le zoom
généralisé
alors attends moi maintenant zoom je
suis à peu près à 800
qui donne des très bons concerts un clic
à droite
allez avec ma main droite puisque elle
est restée
même si j'ai un petit j'ai un handicap
de de handicap à la main droite
des autres vous voulez vous continuez
pardon
quand je clique sur Partager l'écran si
on zoom il me dit cela arrêtera le
partage d'écran
continue
et je te partage quel écran à chaque
fois
vous voyez bien quand même vous voyez
bien un truc
on est d'accord que c'est quoi ça bon je
te vois plus ton écran mais
je comprends pas là tu vas partager ton
écran
non
le copilote il est il est aussi bon que
le pilote on est on est pas très bien
moi je vous le dis attends
je vais essayer un autre
[Musique]
un autre serveur
ça marche ce qu'on va faire
c'est je vais changer de je vais changer
ça doit être bon on va faire ça
surtout pas non mais là je me suis je me
suis planté
parce que là la partie de ce vin
Nakamura c'est hyper théorique je ne
connais rien du tout il y a tout emprise
tous les pions regardez-moi ça ah il
faut que je regarde ah non c'est pas
terrible
ok tu as fait comment
j'ai ouvert un autre Google Chrome ça
marche
j'utilise Microsoft Edge
pour être sur ledge
mais ça ne marche pas du tout
sinon je peux je peux ouvrir un mais non
mais en fait j'ai ça je vais essayer de
recentrer
les chéquier
et est-ce que au moins les pendules
marchent bon alors ça donne quoi du coup
allez pendule moi je les vois pas chez
toi en fait parce que
sur le stream en fait
on a ça un peu plus décalé à droite pour
qu'on puisse voir la pendule
non mais je crois que la pendule elle va
apparaître
t'inquiète ou pas
elle devrait je vais te montrer on va
essayer de
normalement elle devrait apparaître
c'est pas sûr
vous savez quoi on va faire ça
on va faire ça pardon
je suis vraiment désolé je m'excuse
c'est pas la bonne couleur c'est rien
mais au moins on allait
au moins on peut suivre
alors du coup alors cette ouverture je
ne comprends rien il y a à peu près tout
en prise j'espère que toi tu alors moi
ça me dit quelque chose ce truc parce
que j'ai déjà en tant que joueur
agressif de joueurs de fiancéto direct
tu vois puis on prend Camelia 3 voilà on
essaie de récupérer et c'est 5 et censé
être l'antidote pour pouvoir régler tous
ces problèmes et on fait ces 6 voilà
comme ça sur pion prend ces quatre on
fait qu'elle est prend C4 et on est bien
C3 et maintenant que les quatre ça je
connais pas mais attention ça va très
bien préparé toujours toujours la
symétrie parfaite mais tant de plus pour
les blancs
elle peut mal tourner cette blague
quebecca puis on prend fou prend et à
trois ok intéressant qu'est-ce que ça
donne j'en sais absolument rien
il faut calculer maintenant j'ai les
lignes là
me reprendre ton ton
je te partage d'écran
[Musique]
de jouer par Nakamura un coup très
responsable alors pourquoi et bien tout
simplement sur dame prend des quatre il
y avait la fourchette la méchante
fourchette on ramasse la tour et donc en
fait on donnait pas vraiment et regardez
là il joue solide du carreau il va faire
ça va faire nul cette partie on va avoir
en B2
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure il y a
deux points d'avance
je pense que si je suis devant ouais on
va voir alors on regarde
on va voir les coings contre Collard
normalement les caméras vont marcher là
cette fois pour pour au moins les
caméras normalement sont pas en PLS
[Musique]
et donc
qui va apparaître sous vos yeux ébahis
qui est mieux et pourquoi
personne
ben les noirs sont long terme ils ont du
four à trois qui peut être marrant
es
avec ton temps passé là
en fait stratégie de match qui est juste
bonne parce que du coup ils savent
qu'ils ont deux points d'avance ils
savent que c'est prennent pas de caisse
d'un priori le match
il suffit de tenir
donc là maintenant on a une partie
importante ouais une partie décisive
entre wood world
et
son homologue Frédéric vaneux que l'on
va retrouver tout de suite
donc
assez assez solide pour les blancs il y
a un cavalent des six qui pourrait un
jour ça détestabiliser on voit le plan
de 5 qui est en prison
mais bon j'ai quand même des cadres fais
attention
à la caméra il est jamais content
ouais il est un peu il est un peu soit
il excité soit il est toujours un truc
on l'a vu dans 5 minutes
puis on prend et
est-ce que ça fait pas nul ici
[Musique]
ben le match le match est quasi
quoi
qui va faire nul et ça c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle évidemment pour
l'équipe du caronakamura une nul sur
cette échiquier bon là faut absolument
que books ça gagne que hein
ouais mais il y a peut-être un il peut y
avoir une embellie sur un autre
échiquier mais elle est moins bien
Joséphine Heineman dans cette position
on va la ouais elle est beaucoup moins
bien voilà ça sent ça sent le Roussille
la colonne E pour les blancs qui va
venir en F5 peut-être
un Caval blanc qui pourra venir en 2,5
pour les Noirs faudrait vraiment un
miracle dans ce match là pour qu'il se
passe quelque chose à partir de
maintenant
sur lequel il faut un miracle donc ça
m'a l'air vraiment
oui ça commence à faire beaucoup et
effectivement
il faut deux miracles sans cette partie
ça fait beaucoup
ouais
non ça se fait
c'est clair
il y a le
à voir s'il y a quand même pas du tout
c'est 8 un jour
je te prends le pire des hein
Le Puy-en-Velay ça c'est le toi tu joues
le foot
Dame des trois fou B6 d'un F5 a été joué
dame F6
plus ton B7
je vais jouer tout seul
[Musique]
et que la domination
de la tour par rapport à la tour des
vides
terminé terminé cette ce match quasiment
alors vraiment faudrait miracle
[Musique]
était décidément ça ne fait un stream
alors ben voilà voie droite c'est écrit
sur ton écran un point un point à faire
pour les Gotham Knights et ils sont
moins bien nulle part sur les trois
parties restantes et ils sont gagnants
sur une donc autant vous dire que c'est
mission impossible pour nos amis de
berline Beers qui sont bien battus quand
même et notamment einman qui a gagné une
partie incroyable contre les carreaux
Nakamura personne s'y attendait vraiment
on aurait pas mis ça valait le code
en plus il a fait des six F5 et un bout
de quelques minutes qu'il avait un
énorme avantage et mais bon je pense
qu'il était trop en freestyle
[Musique]
ouais un peu trop un peu trop sûr de lui
et voilà comme quoi lui c'est la ronde 1
il joue contre
le joueur le moins fort la joueuse
l'homme le moins forte
il est en string bon je pense qu'il
était un peu
en aka
un peu trop sûr de lui écoute ça force
aussi une force ah oui c'est comme mon
gars souvent
débat avec népot pourquoi il joue aussi
vite pourquoi il gaffe ben ouais en fait
ça force mais la pression et puis au
final ben des fois des fois tu pars des
parties mais après combien de temps à
gagner grâce à la grâce à ce jeu là
beaucoup donc exactement
donc voilà c'est ça va être on va voir
on va voir Naka peut-être mais la case
passe pas grand chose malheureusement la
position comme ça il va tout tenter
mais il a plus trop de temps déjà et
voilà il fait il fait dans la tête il
sait pas ce qu'il fait en fait il arrête
pas de parler évidemment il est en
stream
[Musique]
et donc ça va faire très probablement
nul et faudra expirer un exploitant
le dernier qui a une chance ah il est
bien connard alors peut-être alors
peut-être
aller voir colors ça c'est le premier la
première exacte exact c'est le premier
truc c'est le c'est ce qu'il faut c'est
ça le premier
[Musique]
condition miracle miracle
premier miracle il en faut un deuxième
et là le deuxième je sais pas où on va
la voir parce que je pense pas que ces
event qui va gagner après Cavalo 3
2 on compte pas sur lui
le seul espoir que j'avais
comptez bien là-dessus d'ailleurs
attends ouais tu l'as pas eu du tout et
parce qu'il est il est si gagnant que ça
c'est facile que ça bah
tous les deux qui va arriver j'ai roi E4
qui a l'air chiant j'ai quand même pas
mal de
son son
mais bon
je sais pas il faut calculer les finales
là déjà il faut défendre déjà c'est
toujours moi j'ai 6 peut commencer par
jouer
par jour peut-être j'ai tout rêve ce qui
arrive j'ai tous ces quatre qui arrivent
ce que j'arrive pas à juger c'est ça
une sorte de finale
je suis bien j'ai pu en passer mais toi
aussi donc il a joué cap d'ailleurs
l'écran il aime pas l'ordinateur
est-ce que ça se voit ce genre de truc
ça joue toujours autant
et c'est ce qu'il vient de faire prise
et il pousse Collard deux minutes 37
contre une 13
bon on joue la roi G6 roi et j'ai
G6
et sur le problème de de tour D1 c'est
que je fais tour des deux et j'ai
pantalon
je me laisse faire ça et hop pardon tu
fais ça pour être dans le carré
et sur G3 tt 3 en retard
tu es trop en retard étape pas atteint
un pantalon beaucoup moins beau parce
que il va comme ça et comme ça et moi il
est beaucoup plus long mon pantalon
donc
il a l'air cuit il a joué il a joué quoi
il réfléchit les cons il est cuit dur à
mon avis en plus même au temps elle a 30
secondes contre 2 minutes 30 c'est le
combat perdu allez on va voir
peut-être ouais bon c'est moins grave
que tout à l'heure on a l'impression
tour des deux tu joues comment
d'ailleurs tu manges
si tu as envie de si à chaque fois tu me
sacrifies un peu je le prends tu arrêtes
de la variante des forces épure d'abord
parce que je vais prendre ok bon
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça a fait tourner
après je comprends qu'elle soit en mode
un peu en ligne quoi elle va faire son
plan elle a pas de jeu je crois
[Musique]
cette partie n'a plus aucun intérêt et
va de comme Nakamura c'est quoi la
position
alors peut-être attends on va voir ça
tout de suite on a raté que Naka il
jouait la gagne à fond pour le pour le
chat
il joue pour le chat
[Musique]
pour l'équipe c'est pas terrible ce
qu'il a fait
pas mal aussi tu vois le matin avec
taureau de T3 en fait peut-être il va
être
précis
quelle précision
D3
en plus
rigoler belle partie du corps on a qu'à
moi bravo à lui et bravo Gotham Knight
qui gagne 8 et demi cinq et demi on va
aller voir les deux parties est-ce qu'il
arrive un peu à sauver l'honneur Colars
et bien c'est très très probable il va
finir par la gagner parce que même il y
a sur C4 un petit roi E5
OK
est-ce que je peux passer un jour avec
toi H4 peut-être peut-être
pas gagné avec un pion quoi même si je
prends
[Musique]
exact alors est-ce que je
trouve que ça était un temps en fait en
vrai
on va peut-être plus simple
plus simple
les ganglions
de contre 30 c'est très bien
très vite évidemment et il a joué ta
ligne j'aime bien ta ligne
et ouais
quelque chose
[Musique]
dont j'ai deux et là du coup ouais là
c'est pas bon quoi parce que c'est le
pion c'est au lieu du Piona donc ça va
gagner tout seul pour les blancs il va
abandonner même les coins quoi il va pas
se fatiguer il a bien raison il a dû
abandonner on va aller voir il y a un
ennemi partout et ça joue toujours chez
Joséphine et
et Natalia la finale qui est nulle qu'il
faut défendre avec aussi peu de temps
c'est jamais complètement évident on va
finir sur ces
sur la partie entre Joséphine une partie
comme ça que j'ai commenté l'autre jour
en string c'était quoi une partie qui a
été perdue comme ça
le tournoi de
Napoléon là
c'était
Eliott papa diamant ce qu'il a perdu
contre tigrane-gargan
F6 qui a été joué
un petit peu
[Musique]
en tout cas à créer des problèmes
c'est toujours c'est toujours compliqué
à gérer
pousser F5 ou pas ouais parce qu'on est
obligé si elle est bleu il y a un moment
il faut pousser sinon on s'en sort pas
mais bon ça fait nul quand même en fait
on va réussir à échanger un pion et puis
après il faut juste connaître ces
finales connaître le petit filet d'or
qui devrait
faire nul bon le tout ne se attends
c'est le premier match là quand même ils
sont ils sont à beau logo ils sont quand
même pas mauvais c'est Berlin et il joue
surtout contre une très très grosse
équipe night ça rigole pas là en plus
ils ont ils ont trouvé quand même le
gamin le gamin ténieux de 13 ans qui a
2004 là c'est quand même c'est la super
recrue ils font ça très professionnel
mais je me trompe peut-être
je crois Colas qui a fait qui aura fait
si gagne celle un an il a fait quoi il a
battu les Kong
oui il a fait que deux sur quatre
connards il a perdu contre une belle
position
très homogène l'équipe allemande un
ennemi trois ans et demi 1 à 2 et il
gagne grâce à leurs deux locomotives
ICAO Nakamura et les Kong bien sûr il a
un petit moment de faiblesse mais quand
même trois victoires
de premier alors qu'il faut faire 8 et
demi pour gagner le match
avant le match et
voilà c'était pas le match le plus serré
de l'histoire clairement on va pas
mentir parce qu'il a fallu en fait il a
fallu l'exploiter
le match intéressant
ah oui parce que c'est clair hein
si Naka gagne comme il va quand même
gagner très très souvent
le match le match est payé
8 4 mais bon
est-ce que là on peut faire
ouais ce qu'elle fait quand même
pas grand pas de problème là normalement
aucun problème et ça joue pour du beurre
surtout huitième et demi déjà
peut-être qu'elle le savent pas ouais
ton roi il est
pas de découvertes
maintenant tu fais G6
[Musique]
tu arrives pour le moment le plus
intéressant je sais pas j'ai
pas son comble ça joue ça joue le gain
du match
presque la jouer
donc victoire sur la dernière partie de
Gotham Knight
9 7
on fait un petit truc pour GB tu vois on
essaie de faire entrer dans le truc quoi
donc voilà c'est chaud mais elle a
réussi à tenir cette finale de tour qui
était en perdante mais
donc nul et 9 7 pour Gotham Knight
écoute victoire très logique et attendue
des Américains et malgré la défaite de
la Cameron elle contre Joséphine
d'ailleurs à Man
donc comme quoi franchement comme quoi
tout est possible et voilà là on a les
résultats
individuel donc on a les Allemands qui
ont fait donc
rasmusvane 1 et demi Colars deux points
Frédéric
zaneman deux points donc tu vois on
espère on espère que c'est la seule
équipe allemande par contre ah oui parce
que là disons on va pas commencer
monstrueux quand tu vois que Joséphine
elle a fait enfin c'est elle qui a fait
le plus enfin le meilleur score de
l'équipe
c'est vrai de avec
moi
[Musique]
un ami à 13 ans et en face une amie 2420
enfin franchement
belle
performance de Joséphine qui aura pas
suffi à son équipe on va voir ce qui
nous attend dès demain donc on a les
fous arches Saint-Louis donc c'est une
équipe américaine face au tigre de tu le
sais Stéphane
j'avais le truc juste là attends j'avais
les appareils non ça va être là dans
cette équipe il faut venir demain pour
savoir à mon avis c'est pour ça
qu'il est en équipe mais là demain il
est pas équipé mais peut-être pas demain
c'est Dominguez devant j'ai vu et en
face les Shanghai
je crois qu'il est tranquille
et tu as une équipe qui je trouve assez
faible par rapport à ce moment là
méfie-toi on s'est dit pareil au
Championnat du Monde par équipe ils ont
envoyé l'équipe 18 euh
ils nous ont rasé de A à Z le numéro 2
j'ai vu que c'était je crois
Johan June
[Musique]
et son prénom je crois que c'est i voilà
il a pas fait chinois deuxième langue on
attend parce qu'il va nous en vouloir
encore on espère
par contre le quatrième je le connais
enfin je le connais je connais le nom
quelque part c'est Louis pingouin
et alors à 19h on a quoi et ensuite à
19h on aura le courage scan bouledogs
contre California unigrance donc
c'est chaud donc les Croates donc un pod
dan Diak
le jour
et tu as livaich
et ensuite je crois que c'est un
allemand en allemand
c'est pas du tout allemand je crois que
c'est un indien mais je suis pas sûr
hein dernier cheval
j'ai un truc j'en ai pas
et après bien sûr la Russe chovaloa
Chupa elle joue toujours répartie
marrante et sympa à regarder et
contre Californie
Robson
meilleur et fois genre ok belle équipe
aussi bon on verra tout ça demain
évidemment
on se met bien pour demain on rappelle
donc ça sera 8h30
il faut arriver premier à 8h30 le format
vous le connaissez c'est 16h30 enfin
16h15 donc prise d'antenne on est là
16h15 non
on sera là un petit quart d'heure avant
toi alors c'est pas parce que
demain prévoit les annuaires
[Rires]
je suis peut-être beaucoup
j'ai mal cadré voilà c'est comme ça
s'arrêter
en fait
je sais pas bref désolé il y a eu un
petit léger problème technique mais en
fait ça allait il y a ça froze encore
une fois la poisse dans seulement je
suis pas doué mais en plus j'ai la
poisse sur la technique donc ça c'est
quand même
c'est une combinaison quand même assez
désagréable mais en tout cas on
progresse on progresse
on remercie infiniment ceux qui en
coulisse nous aide notamment Nathan
Vanessa
qui nous file quand même des bons coups
de main je te remercie c'était très
sympa pour le premier stream
et on vous remercie évidemment à tous de
nous avoir suivis d'avoir commenté dans
le chat et on vous donne rendez-vous dès
demain même endroit et beaucoup plus tôt
par contre 16h15 pour suivre la dernière
journée de cette première journée de
prochesse League comprenne qui pourra
ciao ciao bonne soirée merci à bientôt à
tous